Now, we're ready for the next step.
So far, you've seen quite
a few buttons and labels.
But remember, the UI kit offers
a diverse palette of UI controls.
This gives us the freedom to
choose UI elements that make for
the most intuitive user experience.
In the next step, Color Maker,
we have three UI switch controls.
Which are fairly similar to buttons
with one new type of event.
When the user flips the switches,
we see the combination of the three
color components in the window.
Here we'll use three controls
hooked up to three outlets and
we'll route the events from all
three into a single action.
The code and story board
are complete but the outlets and
actions aren't connected yet.
Go ahead and download the project
from the downloadable section.